parole à madame nicole ameline merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
affaires européennes monsieur le
ministre l'europe joue une part
historique de sa responsabilité de sa
crédibilité dans son engagement en
méditerranée singulièrement dans
l'accompagnement de l'accord interdit
bien qui est aujourd'hui en signature au
maroc
résultat d'un compromis politique
largement soutenu par la communauté
internationale
cet accord certes fragile constitue
néanmoins une étape absolument essentiel
si l'on veut éviter que syrte ne
devienne racaille que la libye ne
devienne le nouvel épicentre du
terrorisme et un danger mortel pour
l'ensemble de la région consolider cet
accord on construire aider les libyens à
retrouver une gouvernance à sécuriser
leur pays à mobiliser leurs forces
constituent à n'en pas douter une
responsabilité essentielle pour l'europe
vous venait d'indiquer que l'europe est
le premier bailleur de fonds mondial en
termes de développement ma question est
la suivante comment l'europe peut-elle
redéployer ses financements dans la
méditerranée où l'enjeu de stabilité est
considérable
sous quelle forme voyez-vous cet
engagement est ce que la france est
prête à soutenir une nouvelle résolution
au conseil de sécurité
et enfin quel rôle la france et les pays
riverains de la méditerranée
peuvent-ils jouer dans cette nouvelle
nouveau contexte sachant que la sécurité
de la libye est évidemment un élément de
notre propre sécurité
merci merci madame la parole à monsieur
le secrétaire d'état